I WILL SEND IT BACK TO YOU,
AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, JILLIAN.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
VISIT THE BORDER TODAY FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE LEAVING OFFICE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL TOUR
McALLEN, TEXAS WITH GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT ABOUT 800 MILES
FARTHER SOUTH THAN VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS’ VISIT LAST
WEEK.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WANTS VISIT
COMES AS IMMIGRATION AGENTS FIND
AND THEY RESCUE, LOOK AT THAT A
2-YEAR-OLD LITTLE BOY ABANDONED
BY THE SIDE OF THE ROAD IN
MEXICO.
IT TEXAS SHERIFF IS JOINING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT ON HIS TRIP
TODAY AND HE JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SHERIFF.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
AND GOD BLESS YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME.
AINSLEY: GOD BLESS YOU.
I PRAY THAT HE ALWAYS KEEPS YOU
AND YOUR MEN AND WOMEN SAFE.
TELL ME WHAT YOUR ROLE IS TODAY.
YOU WILL BE MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> I WILL BE.
MY BRIEFING WILL BE SPECIFICALLY
WHAT IS COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
DOESN’T STAY ON THE BORDER.
WE KNOW IT GOES OUT AND ONE OF
THE MAINLY HUBS UNFORTUNATELY
LIVE IS THE DALLAS-FORT WORTH
AREA WHERE IT GOES NORTH AND UP
AND OUT AND IT’S THE DRUG ISSUES
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING ISSUES.
SPECIFICALLY I I I WILL BE TALKI
ABOUT THE THREAT OF FENTANYL TO
OUR COUNTRY.
IT IS A CLEAR AND PRESENT THREAT
SINCE FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR.
TEXAS LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS SEIZED
ENOUGH FENTANYL TO KILL EVERY
MAN, WOMAN, AND CHILD IN THE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
AND IF THAT ISN’T SHOCKING
ENOUGH, WE’RE SEEING A 50%
INCREASE IN FATAL OVERDOSES IN
THE GREATER TARRANT COUNTY AREA.
I HAVE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
THAT THREAT.
AINSLEY: TO THE AVERAGE VIEWER
AT HOME I’M NOT GOING TO SEE
THIS FENTANYL.
WE INTERVIEWED SOME PARENTS
RECENTLY AND THEY TALKED ABOUT
HOW THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN, REALLY
YOUNG TEENAGERS DIED BECAUSE
THEY TOOK ONE DRUG THEY THOUGHT
IT WAS ONE THING IT WAS
SOMETHING ELSE.
LACED WITH ANOTHER DRUG.
HOW SERIOUS IS THIS?
>> IT’S INCREDIBLY SERIOUS.
WHAT WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS EVEN
THE LOW LEVEL DEALERS HAVE WERE
HEROIN LACING AND DESIGNER
DISCUSSION KIDS USE.
SEEING POPULATIONS OF BETWEEN 16
AND 24.
BEING A COMPLETE -- THAT THEY
ARE -- THAT AGE GROUP RIGHT
THERE IS WHO WE ARE LOSING TO
THIS.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY TO THE
PARENTS, WHETHER THEY’RE SITTING
IN NEW YORK OR SITTING IN
CALIFORNIA, FOLKS, PLEASE INVADE
THE SPACE OF YOUR CHILDREN.
KNOW WHO THEY ARE TALKING.
TO SAY SEE WHAT’S GOING ON IN
SOCIAL MEDIA.
BECAUSE THIS LOOKS LIKE A SAFE
DRUG.
THEY ARE USING PILL PRESSES AND
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS ISN’T ANY
MORE DANGEROUS THAN MARIJUANA OR
PRESCRIPTION DRUG IT’S DEADLY.
AINSLEY: ALMOST 300 PERCENT RISE
IN FENTANYL SEIZURES THIS MAY
COMPARED TO LAST MAY.
KAMALA HARRIS IS SAYING IT’S NOT
THEIR FAULT THEY INHERITED THIS
SITUATION.
>> AS YOU KNOW, WE INHERITED A
TOUGH SITUATION.
LOOKED AT A SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN HOUSED IN INHUMANE
CONDITIONS OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS.
AN ASYLUM SYSTEM THAT HAS BEEN
BROKEN.
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
RECONSTRUCTED.
AND AND IN FIVE MONTH WE HAVE
MADE MORE PROGRESS.
THERE IS STILL WORK TO BE DONE
BUT WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO
THAT SHERIFF?
>> MY REACTION IS VERY CLEAR ON
THE STREETS OF TEXAS TODAY AND
IN JANUARY, METHAMPHETAMINE,
ANOTHER DEADLY DRUG THAT’S LACED
WITH FENTANYL WAS GOING FOR $50
A GRAM.
TODAY YOU CAN BUY IT FOR 15 TO
$20 A GRAM.
THE INCREDIBLE SEIZURES OF
DRUGS.
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE CAUGHT
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE CAUGHT IN
COUNTRY UP IN THE TARRANT COUNTY
AND DALLAS COUNTY AREA HUGE
AMOUNT OF DRUGS SEIZED THERE
ISN’T ANY PROGRESS.
THE BORDER IS OPEN.
AND TALKING ABOUT THE KIDS
COMING ACROSS WE HAVE A CRISIS
ON THE BORDER AND GROWING ACROSS
AMERICA.
DRAW A LINE IN THE SAND SOME
PLACE AND TAKE CARE OF IT WE
HAVE HEROIC BORDER SHERIFFS DO
INCREDIBLE JOB WITH PARTNERS AND
DPS.
AINSLEY: SHERIFF, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING YOU ARE
DOING, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ENJOY YOUR DAY WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND WITH THE GOVERNOR.